herida es sin poder caminar su
apartamento voló en pedazos esta anciana
residente de un edificio de nueve
plantas en un distrito al norte de kiev
es rescatada por los bomberos es una de
las afortunadas los rescatistas
continuaron buscando a los heridos el
lunes saltando de una ventana a otra
entre los escombros y los restos
carbonizados de lo que una vez fue una
comunidad alrededor de las 740 a un
bombardeo ruso alcanzó este edificio
residencial en el distrito de obolon en
la capital destruyendo varios pisos el
ataque se produce mientras las tropas
rusas se acercan a la ciudad y golpean
con dureza a otras ciudades y pueblos de
ucrania en kiev los heridos graves
fueron trasladados al hospital donde se
unen a los soldados ucranianos heridos
en los combates con el ejército ruso era
agricultor antes de que rusia invadiera
tengo la intención de volver
directamente a la lucha los rusos lo
tomaran que si la toman tendrán que
levantarla hasta el suelo
no podemos entender esto por qué está
pasando esto aquí nuestra gente es muy
pacífica y quiere vivir solo
es ataques aéreos de kiev contra
viviendas de civiles se producen
mientras rusia y ucrania retoman las
conversaciones en un intento hasta ahora
inútil de negociar un alto el fuego